Russia is not only
using drones
and missiles in this conflict.
Disinformation is one of
its most powerful weapons.
There's no shortage of examples.
Putin's claim in his speech
that the West was preparing
for aggression in Ukraine.
The insistence
that atrocities in Butcher was s
and perhaps one of the most stri
an accusation
that Ukraine was planning to det
a dirty bomb on its own territor
as a set up of Russia
is seen as close to action repor
on what
this bizarre claim
reveals about Russian tactics
No one has ever successfully
detonated a dirty bomb.
So to help us understand
Russia's accusations
and the myths
put on this,
David Butler
a retired British Army officer,
an expert in radiological weapon
has agreed to do a basic
demonstration ready
Butler used
regular explosives here
to disperse a kilo of plain flou
A dirty bomb would also use
regular explosives
to disperse a radioactive substa
Very different, though,
from a nuclear bomb,
which creates a complex chain re
by splitting atoms.
So, David, it's
pretty windy conditions today,
but what does this teach us abou
how a radioactive substance
could spread from a dirty bomb a
The main
aim of a dirty bomb is to spread
as much
irradiated shrapnel
and irradiated dust particles
as far as you can go.
So the flower here demonstrates
what would be left around
the actual site of the explosion
But is the radioactive footprint
on the ground
that causes the long term effect
It is very simple.
We even know where they are
manufacturing it.
Russia's accusation
Ukraine was allegedly planning
to detonate a dirty bomb
on its own territory.
To frame
Russia seemed to come out of the
or did it?
First came state
media reports, citing trusted so
Then unscheduled weekend phone
calls by the Russian defense min
to other nuclear armed powers.
Well produced graphics followed
detailing the alleged sites
where a dirty bomb could be buil
Even the exact radioactive isoto
to be used
This looks as though
it's been planned
in great detail over many weeks,
if not months.
This is straight
out of the sort of Russian playb
in Syria.
The Russians and the Syrians
would suggest
that the rebel forces
are about to create a chemical a
And it was absolutely the Syrian
that were doing it.
Well, inspectors
from the UN's nuclear watchdog h
visited the sites
in Ukraine that Russia named
and found nothing suspicious.
That has not allayed fears in th
that Russia could still use this
as a pretext to escalate,
especially after recent losses
and retreats.
One area of major concern,
according to experts,
is this a Parisian nuclear power
which Russia controls.
One of the aftereffects of a dir
is people breathing in the hazar
The radioactive particles
Well, the physical impact
of a dirty bomb depends
on the amount of radioactive sub
used, the power of the explosive
and the
whether there is one guarantee
effect fear the group.
This was Moscow in 1995 Chechen
buried a radioactive parcel
at a popular park.
Russian authorities
rushed to reassure the public it
no threat.
Is there an element,
do you think that they have laun
this now.
Very elaborate
accusation
against Ukraine of a dirty bomb
because it is something
that has previously
been associated with terror grou
Well, certainly
the Russian propaganda
and disinformation campaign
is in full flow
and trying to depict the Ukraini
as Nazis
and terrorists
is is absolutely
what Putin is trying to do.
The psychological impact
of this carefully
chosen accusation in itself
a powerful weapon.
Sebastian, CNN, near Salisbury,